by joining us now he's the host of CR
TV's Levin TV and the host of life
liberty Levin the number one show right
here Sunday night 10:00 p.m. I call them
the great one well great one I look at
this the part of me and I know how much
you love the Constitution you've
dedicated your entire life to study in
our Constitution writing about our
Constitution talking about it and I read
this and I see an America that doesn't
remind me of the one our founders put
together but a two-tiered justice system
and I it breaks my heart and we have a
lot of work to do if we're gonna fix
this tell you what I see as I went
through this major report here I see
several things number one out of all the
texts all the documents all the emails
that have been reviewed you know it's
interesting Sean there's not a single
pro-trump text there's not a single
anti-hillary text there's not a single
proton senior FBI official there's not a
single anti-hillary FBI official this
was a cabal and these people had as
their purpose to interfere with a
presidential election they interfered
with this presidential election worse
than the Russians could have ever
dreamed of and I am no fan of Vladimir
Putin and the Russians let me tell you
that James Comey sepi I there was
collusion the media in this report
appalling giving gifts and tickets to
sporting events and golf outings in
exchange apparently for leaks you have a
culture of leaks at the FBI the buck
stops were combing this is combing Comey
disgraced McCabe criminal referrals have
you ever heard of an FBI like this you
have obstruction Jim Comey spent months
trying to make sure that Hillary Clinton
was protected you know why because that
they hadn't paddled a federal grand jury
and played by the book she would have
been indicted and the Democrat Party
would have had to have another
convention and find another candidate
they couldn't allow that they had to
defeat Trump combing insubordinate
usurping the powers of the Attorney
General the Deputy Attorney General the
associate Attorney General
insubordinate you have collusion
obstruction insubordination it is
absolutely unbelievable I want to get
back to the media the media which sings
like a bunch of blackbirds on a
telephone pole they move in one
direction they all move in the other
direction now we know why the media was
working much of the media with the FBI
what the Inspector General doesn't tell
us for some reason which media which
reporters which FBI agents we want to
know and they don't tell us now there's
some recommendations that they have in
this report it was hilarious Chuck
Schumer runs to the Senate floor to
immediately defend Comey except as it
comes to Hillary Clinton and says it
starts talking about the report Chuck
Schumer hadn't time to read this report
neither did any other the Democrats
running to the media and they all sound
the same because they all have the same
talking points here's his
recommendations the IG we recommend that
the Department and the FBI consider
developing guidance that identifies the
risks associated with an alternatives
for permitting a witness to attend a
voluntary interview of another witness
that's already Department of Justice
policy what that means is they call me
allowed the Clinton Witnesses to collude
we recommend the Department consider
making explicit that except in
situations where the law requires her
permits disclosure an investigating
agency cannot publicly announce its
recommended charging decision prior to
consulting the Attorney General that's
already Department of Justice policy we
recommend that the Department in the FBI
consider adopting a policy tracing the
appropriateness of Department employees
discussing the conduct of uncharged
individuals in public statements that's
already Department of Justice policy we
recommend that the Department consider
providing guidance to agents and
prosecutors concerning the taking of
overt investigative steps indictments
public announcements or other actions
that could impact an election that's
already Department of Justice policy
I'll tell you what I watched this FBI
director ray have his press conference
and learned exactly nothing
and one of the things he did that I
found very troubling to me is he said
look one of the things we're gonna do to
fix this and we're already on it we're
gonna have very significant training of
all of our agents new agents senior
agents all thousands of agents that they
need to be unbiased in their
investigations and I thought to myself
they are unbiased in their
investigations the vast majority the FBI
is unbiased in investigations while
you're trashing your own agency
the problem isn't Jo FBI agent or Sally
FBI agent the problem is Jim Comey the
problem is McCain the problem is stroke
the problem is Paige the problem is that
whole crowd and I found it incredibly
outrageous that the new FBI director if
once he said I'm defending the FBI it's
a great institution and I happen to know
it is but then on the other hand
everybody needs to be trained not to be
biased this report even though the IG
says he didn't find political bias I
have to say there's bias throughout and
he uses the word throughout but I would
ask the inspector general then what kind
of bias are you talking about racial and
bias
sexual bias religious bias of course it
was political bias as I started out by
saying there's not a single pro-trump
text from any of these FBI agents
there's not a single proton FBI agent
there's supposed to be objective but
they've politicized it to such an extent
and the reason the reason is as I said
they had to protect Hillary Clinton
because she would have and should have
been indicted so Hillary I saw your
little tweet today kind of thinking well
see even Comey used his personal email
for government business but Hillary you
violated the Espionage Act and Jim Comey
protected you you could very well be in
an orange jumpsuit today and I'm quite
quite serious but you aren't and you
should thank God for that great one Mark
Levin by the way I have a message from a
mutual friend Billy says Wow tell mark
great rent
he's on fire tonight thank you sir it's
serious mark its it's you're right she
belongs in jail